et c'est parti ça va pas tarder à partir
quoi enfin il y a des il y a des
peut-être des chances que un jour ou
l'autre ça ça partte ah c'est
parti bleu bleu le ciel de
province blanc blanc blanc le GO et là
le bateau blanc qui danse blanc blanc le
soleil de PL et dans tes yeux mon rêve
en
bleu bleu bleu je m'entends pas ma voix
quand j'ai besoin de vacances alors
attendez on commence alors Monsieur
Stéphan vous êtes gentil c'est moi que
je n'entends pas c'est ma propre voix
n'est-ce pas parce que vous savez que
dans ce disque j'ai enregistré les deux
autres voix ça j'entends parfaitement
mais alors c'est moi que j'entends pas
c'est parti à nouveau 2è édition
attention 8 5 3 9 12 bleu de 14 17 22 5
4 3 2 1 après 0 il y a plus rien 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 12 parce que là normalement il
remonte la bande vous voyez là alors
c'est c'est le c'est le c'est
l'opération Harbour comme la paire du
même
nom c'est moi alors ça c'est c'est c'est
la voilà là parce que voilà c'est
le mais il y en a pas pour longtemps
hein gu normalement je crois que de
toute façon mon cher Maître ah il ah
c'est parti j'is proposer de chanter
c'est parti c'est parti c'est parti ça y
est
pour l'instant ça marche pas mal bleu
bleu le ciel de
province très bien voyez quand vous
voulez blanc blanc le Goé le bateau
blanc qui danse BL BLB le sil de plomb
et dans tes yeux mon rêve
en bleu
bleu quand j'ai besoin de vacan ble ble
blelele bleu ble ble bleu comme un ciel
immensele et nous partons tous les deux
on s va
là bleu
bleu bleu bleu le ciel de
province BL blanc blanc le goéran le
bateau blanc qui danse blanc blanc le
soleil du plomb et dans tes yeux mon
rêve en
bleu bleu
bleu
quand le vent claque la
toi de ton joli Jon
blanc
blanc blanc comme une voile je
navigue et perd du
main bleu bleu le ciel de
province blanc blanc blanc le GO le
bateau blanc qui danse blan blanc soleil
de PL et dans tes yeux mon rêve en
bleu bleu
bleu deses cheveux d'un blond de rêve BL
BL des ferles d'un flot
léger BL BL sur une grève où je
voudrais
nafrag bleu bleu le ciel de prova
[Musique]
blanc blanc blanc le Goé le bateau blanc
qui danse blanc blanc le soleil de PL et
dans tes yeux mon
ble bleu
bleu bleule blan BL bleu blan blle blan
bllean
bllele